what's up my name's Samuel Leeds I'm
standing right now in Detroit Michigan
in the United States of America this is
Apparently one of the cheapest areas in
the world to buy properties certainly in
the western world and I've been looking
at some of these houses and they are
absolutely cheap as chips I'm in this
house right now it does need quite a bit
of work as you can see but it's a big
house with a lot of land it's on the
market with bellerby estates this house
is on the market for five thousand
dollars that is around about four
thousand pounds absolute Madness
um there's loads I'll take it I'll take
you to a couple of practice
what did you think when I first showed
you the prices of these houses
I couldn't believe it I can't believe
how cheap what do you actually think of
the area does it feel nice does it feel
horrible what do you think actually
being here it's not too bad it's not the
best area in the world but considering
the prices it's Madness yeah right let's
head down to the next viewing how far is
it
it's about 50 minutes I think
oh
my goodness
they're all totally derelict look at
that one there on the left
she
is just
it just needs to be knocked down doesn't
it look at that one look at the roof oh
it's okay
[Music]
they're dangerous
cheers all the trees growing around it
abandoned
this feels like a worst part of town
than the last one yeah which is why this
one's 750
cheaper
okay where is it
might be
looking for this is the road oh wow look
at that
okay so this house
here's the big catch though the big
catch is if you buy a house you're
buying it from a company called Land
Bank Authority
and they'll sell you the house on the
condition that you have to refurbish the
house the average house in Detroit is
around about 75 000 is some of these
areas probably the ones that are in good
condition are only worth twenty thousand
so if you buy it for four thousand
you have to spend 20 000 doing it up and
if you've got to do it up as part of the
transaction and they'll monitor you
you're not actually making any money you
may as well just buy one for 25 000 it's
already in good condition
so it's not quite as attractive as you
think but still shoot I like the first
one better this this this area doesn't
feel great let's go
let's get out of here
this area feels very dead
um it feels like there's not that much
going on around
yeah it's almost like a bit like a ghost
town isn't it it is a bit uh
interestingly this street is the street
where Eminem Slim Shady who's like a
hero of mine grew up in his house was
right here on this little grass
next door neighbor's house
what would have like turned into a
museum or something but instead you just
got dirt cheap houses all around the
area
call this yeah graffiti empty derelicts
like five cars on the whole Road I know
it's crazy
but we're one minute away from our next
viewing
so bad news unfortunately
this house as you can see is now sold
the land bank Authority
when they're selling houses the idea is
that they're selling it to people from
the area that are going to live in the
house so as an investor like me you can
buy houses like this for the price you
can but you've got to get on the list
you've got to register a company that's
in Michigan you've got to commit to
spending the money on it if it's empty
you're paying council tax and the taxes
are a few thousand pounds a year so if
you just buy something like this and
think oh I'll buy it for seven grams and
just sit on it and hope that one day it
becomes worth a hundred thousand pounds
and they regenerate the area while
you're waiting for them to regenerate
the area which could take a very long
time you're paying council tax unless
the properties lived in and then I
imagine the tenant would pay but if the
property's lived in then you're gonna
have to refurb it and how much are you
going to spend to refill property like
that
hello what are you thinking Amanda what
do you think about the idea of buying
one of these big cheap houses
good bad I don't know probably I feel
like it's an area that might be
um regentrified and have lots of
development in the future you can
imagine it can't you yeah because in 20
years time or 30 years time you can
imagine that houses like this house
could be worth like a million bucks
couldn't it yeah which right now is on
the market for seven thousand Pounds
come on you're a Qs tell me let's go and
have a quick look at this how much
to turn this out into a livable
habitable space what do you reckon I
think a couple hundred thousand a couple
hundred thousand so that's not a big
problem there isn't it don't make any
sense yeah they can give you the house
for free
but the end value is only going to be in
this area what 70 grand so if you're if
you're if you're buying it they could
pay me
they could pay us
20 grand to have that house and then
we're gonna have to pay council tax if
it's empty and if we refurbish it they
cost 200 000 and the invite seventy
thousand
don't actually make any sense
no because most of them are literally
falling down that won't be structurally
sound unless you could find one whereby
it was actually in okay condition ready
to rent yeah because I'm surprised at
the rent the rents are like 1500 pounds
you know the houses are cheap the rent's
quite High
interesting what do you think let us
know in the comments I'll read everyone
would you consider dumping five grand
and buying a house out in Detroit
Michigan or do you think it's a waste of
time resource and money let me know in
the comments I'd love to know your
thoughts personally Amanda what are you
saying
I think I think no I'm agreeing with
Amanda or maybe you think different let
us know in the comments two hours later
I'm buying one of those houses now
[Music]